[Musique]
si ça vous convient on va commencer par
un toc de 12 minutes avec mon horaire de
300 euros ça nous fait du 90 euros
chacun le tout pour entamer sereinement
une procédure qui va durer à peu près
dix ans oui j'ai une confession à vous
faire je suis avocat je sais ce que vous
dites j'étais bien montaut que les
speakers était inspirant le thème était
exaltant et là monsieur l'avocat m il ya
de parler de droit
oui mais en fait le droit c'est juste
notre quotidien c'est vrai on vit dans
une matière première
invisible qui s'appelle la norme on
mange de la norme respire de la norme et
on accepte même une administration que
l'on ne connaît pas nos juges sur le
respect de cette norme et pendant très
longtemps je me suis demandé pourquoi
pourquoi j'accepte de me plier à cette
autorité
pourquoi j'accepte que cette
administration puisse me priver de ma
liberté
une des réponses du moins ma réponse
c'est la justice c'est parce que je sais
que peu importe d'où je viens je
pourrais défendre mes droits
c'est parce que je sais que
l'application du droit sera le même pour
tous
donc vous voyez la justice n'est pas
simplement le cérémonial et robes noires
voire parfois tendance phare dalmatiens
jacques a dit eddy debout assis en
prison non c'est bien plus que ça la
justice c'est le lien de confiance qui
unit les citoyens à l'état
et pourtant j'habite paris et j'ai vu
pendant plusieurs semaines une colère
s'exprimer j'ai vu des voitures brûlées
et je ne peux malheureusement que
constater que ce lien de confiance est
aujourd'hui abîmées et sam amène
naturellement à me demander si nous les
avocats les magistrats
la justice ne vont pas une part de
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe
quand j'ai prêté serment il ya un an
j'ai juré d'exercer mes fonctions avec
dignité conscience indépendance probité
et humanité l'humanité
est ce que ce n'est pas l'humanité que
vous attendez de la justice une justice
qui ne soit pas que punitive mais qui
t'aident véritablement ateret insérer
une justice qui s'attache à ta situation
individuelle et qui est capable aussi de
t'accompagner de te rassurer pourtant je
dois malheureusement admettre que c'est
bien l'humanité que j'ai eu du mal à
retrouver quand j'ai intégré la
profession d'avocat j'ai vu des avocats
préfèrent en pondre des pages juridico
juridique de 150 pages pour protéger
leurs responsabilités plutôt plutôt que
de véritablement conseiller le client
j'ai vu des magistrats jugés à la chaîne
par parfois avec un biais politique et
j'ai vu des justiciables préférant
renoncer à leurs droits
plutôt que d'aller voir un avocat où est
l'humanité mais en 2018 j'ai eu un
déclic un déclic qui a complètement
changé ma manière de concevoir le droit
la relation client vous savez à cette
époque là où commencer à parler de
bloquer india dans plein de domaines
bon voyage il comprenait pas grand chose
mais j'ai eu la chance de développer
pour le ministère de la justice une
plateforme permettant d'aider les
délinquants condamnés à se réinsérer par
le travail d'intérêt général
vous savez c'est toutes ces peines
alternatives aux peines d'emprisonnement
c'est elle qui vous déshumanise
quelqu'un est en france on sait très
bien que les prisons sont surchargées
coûteuse mais à seulement 6
en fin de peine de travaux d'intérêt
généraux qui sont prononcés alors que le
taux de récidive est nettement plus
faible
mais pourquoi déjà la première chose
qu'on a constaté c'est qu'il y avait un
véritable problème d'adéquation entre
les peines qui sont prononcés et le
profil de la personne qui ce qui est
condamné concrètement aujourd'hui c'est
le service pénitentiaire d'insertion et
de probation qui se heurte à la
recherche fastidieuse d'un poste de
tiges disponible qui n'est pas vraiment
adapté au profil de la personne
condamnée et parfois ça peut durer
quelques mois
cinq six mois pour trouver une peine de
travail d'intérêt général ce qui perd
manifestement tout son intérêt
et donc on a créé un système de matching
permettant de mettre en relation le
profil de la personne condamnée avec son
expérience ses compétences son projet
professionnel et la peine qui lui sera
le plus adapté pour le réinsérer dans la
société
ensuite on s'est rendu compte que le
faible taux de tiges venait du fait que
les magistrats étaient assez réticent à
prononcer des peines de travaux
d'intérêt généraux parce qu'il n'avait
pas de réel suivi sur l'exécution de la
peine de tiges dans l'entreprise et pour
cause avait aucun outil est donc on a
créé un tableau de bord permettant de
suivre en temps réel les
accomplissements du tigistes dans
l'entreprise les éventuels manquements
aussi il y donnait à l'issue un
certificat de compétences permettant de
l'aider à retrouver un emploi
de cette expérience j'ai compris une
chose c'est que les légal tech
c'est à dire toutes les nouvelles
technologies dans le domaine juridique
preuves peuvent profondément réhumaniser
l'injustice est donc là j'ai commencé ma
vie j'ai arrêté de me prendre pour le
captain america du droit qui brandit sa
robe tel un justicier et j'ai commencé à
regarder le justiciable
vous savez c'est cette race étrange qui
vient nous voir quand ils ont des
problèmes juridiques dont concrètement
c'est vous et s'avère que vous avez ce
qu'on appelle des besoins et qu'en fait
vous n'attendez pas forcément quand vous
sorte notre chance d'entrer au science
divine légal mais qu'on réponde à vos
besoins et là vous m'avez dit
m oui c'est toujours bon pour l'ego on
veut une réponse rapide à l'est adjugée
mais m on veut aussi du qualitatif et de
l'individuel pourquoi pas mais m on veut
aussi en honoraires forfaitaires
transparent et moins cher merde et je me
suis demandé finalement comment à partir
des nouvelles technologies je pouvais
apporter de votre technologie je pouvais
répondre le plus efficacement possible
aux besoins des clients et donc d'abord
j'ai première chose que j'ai constaté
c'est que dans mon cabinet iv beaucoup
de tâches qui étaient répétitif
fastidieuse et chronophage passé
beaucoup de temps à faire les mêmes
contrats les mêmes recherches et donc
j'ai robotisée tous les contrats dans
mon cabinet tous les documents
juridiques qui fait que lorsqu'un client
vient me voir en quelques minutes je
peux lui produire son document j'ai
drastiquement diminué mais tant de
production alors oui vous vous dit
certainement que cette démarche est plus
industriel car tease qu'individuel mais
je dirais qu'au contraire c'est cette
approche industrielle qui permet de
faire de l'individuel parce que tout ce
temps que j'ai gagné en fait je l' ai
remis dans le client pour l'accompagner
pour le rassurer pour lui expliquer les
différentes étapes de la procédure mais
finalement c'est pas ça que vous
attendez de l'avocat qu'on vous dise
d'où vous venez et vous allez mais les
légats tech ça va beaucoup plus loin
si je vous disais qu'une intelligence
artificielle pourra anticiper l'issue
d'une décision de justice
si vous disais qu'un algorithme pourra
en fonction des circonstances de
l'espèce dû fait déterminer quel sera le
jugement rendu par le juge
c'est pas demain c'est pas après demain
c'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya des sociétés qui font
ce qu'on appelle de l'analyse
statistique des décisions de justice ou
vulgairement parlant de la justice
prédictive et concrètement en fait le
même principe que les prévisions
météorologiques il arrive à déterminer
en fonction des différents éléments des
faits qu'elle sera lé pourcentage de
chance ou de malchance d'être condamné
c'est aujourd'hui
concrètement vous pouvez vous dire
légitimement que ça me par la justice at
justice paraît froide un personnel et
que demain on sera jugé par des robots
je ne pense pas du moins mon expérience
m'amène à penser le contraire
en effet dire qu'aujourd'hui la justice
est la même pour tous relèvent d'une
immense hypocrisie
à titre personnel exerce en droit du
travail et je vois très bien qu'en
fonction des juridictions conçoit paris
versailles et nanterre lyon orléans le
jugement d'une même affaire
peut-être complètement différent et des
conseils de prud'hommes qui sont pros
employeurs d'autres pros salariés et une
profonde inégalité y la justice
prédictif permet d'apporter de la
transparence dans ce processus et de
garantir surtout l'égal accès du droit
pour tous mais si l'utilisation des
nouvelles technologies a été plutôt bien
reçue par mes clients
ça n'a pas été exactement la même chose
de la part de mes confrères faut
imaginer qu'on est une profession
ordinale historiques traditionnelles
haute fashion et imaginez la réaction de
ses avocats installé quand une bande de
petits branleurs sont arrivés et ont dit
on veut mettre plus d'horizontalité dans
les cabinets d'avocats rendent le droit
accessible et utiliser de nouvelles
technologies
on était des terroristes on était les
braconniers du droit qui voulaient
détruire toutes les vertus dignité tout
l'honneur de la profession d'avocat il
faut imaginer mon premier jour à l'école
d'avocats un vieux bâtonnier bedonnant
m'a dit monsieur sauzée vous déshonorez
la profession
quelques semaines après je vais à nantes
pour parler des légal tech et un avocat
se lève
tiens le benalla du droit est arrivé ont
déjà monsieur n'a pas élevé les cochons
ensemble et donc finalement on donc
finalement on se retrouve aujourd'hui
dans une situation où il y avait deux
types de population des avocats
installés qui ont une culture assez
traditionnel et de l'argent et des
jeunes avocats cabine qui ont une
volonté de rendre le droit
plus accessible d'utiliser les nouvelles
technologies mais qui n'ont ni l'argent
ni la formation est donc avec mes amis
julie mathieu on a pris conscience
finalement que cette transformation
digitale était inéluctable car il
correspondait à une évolution finalement
des besoins des clients
c'est un phénomène quelque peu
anthropologique et donc on s'est
rassemblés et on a créé la première
association des jeunes professionnels de
la ligue altec à partir de ça on a pris
notre bâton de pèlerin nous aussi et on
est allé dans les universités dans les
écoles d'avocats dans les écoles de
commerce pour ses dents les barreaux
pour sensibiliser les professionnels aux
problématiques de transformation
digitale
parce que finalement je suis et
aujourd'hui je continue cette démarche à
titre personnel par mon activité en
accompagnant les avocats qui eux sont
installés sur leur transformation
parce qu'à titre personnel je suis
convaincu que cette transformation
digitale doigté man et des avocats et de
fait par les avocats
pour les avocats notre profession est
belle nous sommes les seuls aujourd'hui
apporter des principes déontologiques
qui sont de dévouement à l'égard de nos
clients
le secret professionnel la loyauté
l'humanité nous sommes la seule
profession a porté ces valeurs mais
notre profession est aujourd'hui menacée
menacés parce que d'autres acteurs
privés arrivent sur notre marché
menacée parce que nos modes de
fonctionnement ne correspondent plus
aujourd'hui véritablement aux besoins
des clients des justiciables
donc notre profession de voix évolué et
évoluent et de l'intérieur
si si tous les problèmes de la justice
ne peuvent pas être résout en une
journée
j'en conviens ça ça amène une réflexion
beaucoup plus globale sur la question
des peines pénales de la justice et de
manière générale aussi des de la norme
énorme sur le territoire la légal tech
est aujourd'hui une solution qui est à
notre portée
qui est efficace pour rendre le droit et
la justice beaucoup plus visible
beaucoup plus accessible beaucoup plus
humain comme toute bonne plaidoiries se
termine par des demandes
je vous demande de bien vouloir
constater que la profession d'avocat a
évolué et de bien vouloir écarter vos
clichés
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]